In this video, we'll solve our
linear optimization problem
in the software LibreOffice.
LibreOffice is similar
to Microsoft Excel,
but it's an open
source software,
and is available for
free on the internet.
Another option we could
use is OpenOffice.
You're welcome to use Excel,
OpenOffice, or LibreOffice
in this course, and whenever
we mention LibreOffice,
keep in mind that
you could be using
one of the other
softwares instead.
For more information
about the options,
see the download
instructions on edX.
You should have already
downloaded and installed
LibreOffice.
If not, follow the
instructions on edX
before continuing
with this video.
Go ahead and open the
file, Week9_AirlineRM.ods.
I've already set up the data
for our problem and places
for us to build our
decisions, our objective,
and our constraints.
The decisions are
highlighted in yellow.
These are the number of
regular seats to sell,
and the number of
discount seats to sell.
We'll just leave these
cells blank for now,
since the solver will be
finding the optimal values.
Our objective, which we
saw in the previous video,
is to maximize total revenue.
Let's go ahead and build the
objective in this blue cell.
It should equal the
price of regular seats,
times the number
of regular seats
we sell, plus the price
the discount seats,
times the number of
discount seats we sell.
Go ahead and hit Enter.
You should see 0 in this cell.
That's because right now,
we're not selling any seats.
Our decision cells are blank.
This could be a
little tedious if we
had more than two decisions.
To make it easier, we
can use a nice function
called sumproduct to
build our objective.
So go ahead and
clear the objective.
Now in the objective
cell, let's type
equals, and then sumproduct,
and then in parentheses,
select the two prices,
type a semicolon,
and then select the two seats.
This will multiply the first
price times the first decision
variable, and the second price
times the second decision
variable, and add them up.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
Note that if you're
using Excel, you
should use a comma
instead of a semicolon.
We should again see
0 in our objective.
This is going to have the
exact same value it did before.
Now let's construct
our constraints.
The first constraint is
the capacity constraint.
The green table here allows
us to easily write out
our constraints in terms of
what's on the left-hand side,
LHS, what the sign is,
like equals, less than
or equals, or greater
than or equals,
and what's on the
right-hand side, or RHS,
of the constraint.
So for the capacity
constraint, the left-hand side
is equal to the number
of regular seats
plus the number
of discount seats.
The sign is less than or
equals, and the right-hand side
is 166, the capacity
of our aircraft.
The regular demand constraint
should be the regular number
of seats, which
should be less than
or equal to the regular
demand, which equals 100.
The discount demand
should be the number
of discount seats,
which should be
less than or equal to the
demand, which is equal to 150.
Note here that whenever I
pick the seats or the demand,
I pick those cells
up on the top.
That's because if we want
to change our demand,
we could easily change
it up at the top,
and all of our constraints
will change too.
Now, let's add in our
non-negativity constraints.
So the number of
regular seats should
be greater than or equal
to 0, and the number
of discount seats should be
greater than or equal to 0.
Now we're ready to
solve our problem.
To do this, we just
go to the Tools menu
in LibreOffice
and select Solver.
Now we need to fill in the
information about our problem.
The "Target cell"
should be the objective.
So with the blinking
cursor in the target cell,
select the objective cell.
We should also be
selecting "Maximum",
since we're trying to
maximize the total revenue.
The area called
"By changing cells"
should be our
decision variables,
so go ahead and select
that blank area,
and select the
decision variables.
The "Limiting conditions"
are our constraints.
The "Cell reference" should
be the left-hand side
of the constraint, the
"Operator" is the sign,
and the "Value" is
the right-hand side.
For constraints with the same
sign, if they're in a row,
we could select them at
once to be more efficient.
So first, let's select
the first three less than
or equal to constraints.
We want to make sure the
operator is less than
or equal to, the integer and
binary options you see here,
we'll explain next
week, and the value
should be the right-hand
side of these constraints.
Then we need to add in the
greater than or equal to
constraints.
So select the two
left-hand sides.
The operator should be
greater than or equal to,
and the value should be
the two right-hand sides.
The last thing we want
to do is in Options,
make sure that the LibreOffice
Linear Solver is selected.
Click OK, and then hit Solve.
The solving result should say:
"Solving successfully finished.
Result: 77,408".
This is the objective
of our optimal solution,
and is the total revenue we get.
Go ahead and click Keep Result.
And now back in
our spreadsheet, we
can see that our solution is to
sell 100 regular seats and 66
discount seats.
You may be thinking that
you could have done this
without the Solver.
But when the problems
become more complicated,
it's very difficult
and often impossible
to solve them by hand.
We'll make our problem
more complicated
later in the lecture, and
solve it in LibreOffice.